Speaker 1: Let's go next to Noah from
New Jersey. Noah, you were on the air.
Noah, from New Jersey, you're on the air.
Hey, can you hear me, David? Yes, I can. Cool.
Speaker 4: So I don't know if this is a good
question to ask, it's not maybe as informational.
I kind of have a two part question. I guess so.
I live in a I still live at home with my parents,
and they're both Republicans. My
dad has the vaccine is considering
not getting the booster shot. I just got my
booster shot, OK? And my mom is completely
closed off to the idea of getting the vaccine.
So I just wanted to see if you had any insight
on sort of how to deal with sort of family
interactions when that's sort of the dynamic.
Speaker 1: Well, why doesn't she want the vaccine?
Speaker 4:
She's she's not quite on the level of Q and
Speaker 2: on, but she's kind of,
Speaker 4: you know, a little bit paranoid and
definitely has some misinformation, misinformation
misleading her.
Speaker 1: OK,
like, what does she believe about it?
Speaker 4: Honestly, to be honest, I don't even
really know, I know she doesn't really believe
that there's like I don't think she believes
the whole tracking device thing, but I think
that. She just doesn't think it works, maybe
she doesn't think that's necessary. Yesterday,
she said that my niece has a cold and I said, Is
it definitely cold or is it COVID? And she said,
Well, it's it's definitely a cold because kids
get colds all the time. And I was like, Well,
Speaker 1: yeah, it's not really an argument. So
here's the thing. First, you've got to figure out
what it actually is because you said a few
different things. You said you don't think
she believes the tracking chip stuff, she may
not believe the vaccine works or she may not
believe that the vaccine is necessary. These are
all different things. So my process would be and
obviously you have to decide for yourself how much
you want to argue about this with your mom. But my
Speaker 2: process would be first to
Speaker 1: really figure out by listening
why they don't want the
Speaker 2: vaccine.
Speaker 1: Only when you understand that can we
even go to the next step. The next step would be
figure out what would change their mind. So if
they say, Well, the reason I don't want it is,
I don't think it's safe, you would say,
Well, if your personal doctor told you it was
Speaker 2: safe, would you take it?
Speaker 1: Yeah, I trust my personal
doctor. Great. Try to get her to talk to her
personal doctor. Other people might say, Well,
I don't believe that it's effective.
Then you say, Well, if I showed
Speaker 2: you what
Speaker 1: if who said it was effective,
would you change your mind? And maybe she says,
Well, I don't know if, if, if you showed me data
or whatever the point here is first, you've
really got to understand why she doesn't want
it right now. It doesn't seem like you understand
that well enough to really move on to step two.
Speaker 4: OK, and and do I have time to ask one
other quick question? Yeah, go ahead, go ahead. So
I, you know, I've spent time following people that
maybe, you know, used to be in my life that are
hard core Republicans simply for the the fact
of sort of entertainment stuff that they would
post would be entertaining to me. Sure. So I was I
ended up unfollowing most of those people because
I just felt like it was actually ended up being
Speaker 2: draining to myself,
Speaker 4: and I didn't think it was healthy.
So I just wanted to kind of wondered if you
feel that being so involved in politics and having
to keep yourself updated with it so much if that
sort of drains you mentally.
Speaker 1: Yeah. And so I
have to do this for work. So on my
Speaker 2: Facebook, I have unfollowed
Speaker 1: certain people like that. I went
to high school with that completely lost their
minds. Like, there's there's this one one woman
who I went to high school with, who graduated
with me at the start, I knew she was sort of a
Republican, and before the pandemic she would post
some gun stuff and some religious stuff at
the pandemic. She started posting every insane
Speaker 2: link to every
Speaker 1: conspiracy theory,
vaccine stuff Foushee, Bill Gates, microchips,
everything. Everything, everything. So I just
unfollowed, you know, because it's just, it's
just overload. If I'm just browsing Facebook and
keeping up with what my friends are doing, I
just I just don't need to be seeing that. I do
think the considerations different like I work in
this field. So like when I'm looking at Twitter,
which I use for work, I can't just get rid of
all of the crazy right wing stuff because I'm
reporting on it. I'm covering it, I'm engaging
with it. But yeah, it is draining. And another
thing I recommend is take days off entire
days off. I don't follow what's going on
on the weekends, barely at all. Like, I'll see
my mom on a Sunday morning and she'll be like,
Did you see? And I'll be like, I didn't see it.
I checked out after finishing the Friday show.
So I think scheduled time away
from it is really important.
Thanks, David, thanks for taking my call. All
right, my pleasure. Very good questions there.
I like it. We got a couple dropped calls today,
but the ones that we got were really, really good.